what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
the 28th of july the joint is brought to
you by
bowl and branch you're like joey what's
bowling branch there's nothing
more important than a good night's sleep
bowling branch knows it takes more than
just a good mattress
you gotta have nice sheets bowling brand
sheets are extra
ultra soft plus they're 100 organic
and sustainably produced listen these
sheets are as comfortable
as hell it's like sleeping on a ball of
cotton i've had sheets before that are
nice
i've been in nice hotels bowling brand
are tremendous the sheets are soft
smooth and comfortable
i got my bed looking sharp with the new
natural colored sheets
check out the signature hem sheets
they're the best sellers for a good
reason they get softer
with every rod wash and here's something
else that'll help you sleep
bowling brand sheets are made by
craftsmen who earn a fair living wage
these workers are in the pay and respect
they deserve
get ready for this the bowling branch
guarantee
enjoy any product worry free for three
thirty nights to experience the best
sheets you've ever felt
choose bowling branch you could try them
worry free for 30 nights
with free shipping and returns you're
looking for a gift for grandma
uncle pete uncle joey your sister
this is the way to go the joint
listeners get an exclusive
15 off your first set of sheets with
promo code joey
at bowlingbranch.com b-o-l-l-a-n-d b
r a n c h period dot com
that's bowling branch b-o-l-l
and branch b-r-a-n-c-h dot com
promo code joey you're gonna love these
sheets you're gonna sleep like a baby
especially now that it's hot these
sheets will keep you nice and cool
bowlingbranch.com pressing code joey for
off the joint is also brought to you by
c b d lion the best cbd
product on the market how do i know
because i've tried them all
this is it go to cbdline.com
read the third party lab results and see
what they have to offer from the
capsules to the cbd weed to the roll-on
to the gummy bears which are [__]
tremendous the new ones with melatonin
are [__] sweet you sleep like a baby
if you have an accident take too many
edibles
you pop a little cbd under your tongue
and you're right back normal your heart
will calm down a little bit
and you'll be tip top magoo with cbd
lion
extra strength cbd lotions
roll on bath ball if you want it
they make it cbd line is at the top of
that game
go to cbdlion.com right now read
learn pick something up to help you
press and code joey
and get 20 off your order joey and get
20 off your order right now go to
cbdline.com and press and joey
let's get this party started it's
wednesday
and i [__] up monday let's do this
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint
wednesday the 28th of [__] july
we're almost done with this [__]
month and then it's another month and
the summer's
over then it's another month and the
[__] sopranos are here so it's
perfect
we want to keep these months [__]
going i'm sorry about
monday's podcast i was a little [__]
up
when i taped i don't know what the [__]
was the matter with me maybe i was a
little [__]
i couldn't get the worthing out of my
mouth but that's been going on lately
some days i'm flat some days i'm johnny
bananas
what are you gonna [__] do uh my
teeth are back to [__] normal
i got them worked on on monday only two
stitches this time
it wasn't so bad i did the [__]
laughing gas
but not really not the weed laughing ass
laughing gas laughing gas from the
[__] doctor
but it was terrible i saw you look
usually when you do [__] i haven't done
laughing gas since november 18th 1987
the dad kidnapped bella
and ever since that i never did laughing
gas again because it made me kidnap
somebody no it didn't
i kidnapped him on my own who the [__]
are you kidding that was the last time i
did laughing gas so i called the dentist
last week and i'm like listen that was
traumatizing
all those [__] needles coming it was
like [__] missiles
i can't do it again like i couldn't even
go for blood that week
i was so traumatized by the needles so
they understood
they said you got two options you could
take a [__] pill we could give you a
pill
or you could take laughing gas i said
give me the laughing gas i went down
there yesterday
on monday and the laughing gas was
[__] uh there was no [__]
breathing thing
they put a little tube on my nose with
two little things going in
i'm sitting up looking like [__] miss
piggy that's what i kept thinking
i'm like i'm like miss piggy i'm sitting
here and nothing's [__] happening
nothing was happening i must have sucked
on that [__] laughing gas
for 15 minutes and i said to him can i
go pee before you start
just to walk to see if i was like a
little [__] up nothing
so the laughing gas was like whatever
towards the end i kind of felt it but
it was not i just told him to dope me up
good because the last time
he just put cocaine on me and started
[__] like oh no whoa
you got to put the coke on me and let it
sit a little bit let it sit for eight
minutes and then give me another
[__] shellacking can put another coat
on there and make sure you put something
on the [__] roof of my mouth
cause i'm not gonna tolerate that
[__] needle again that needle to the
mouth
[__] me up my shoulders were tight i
couldn't move my [__] arms i was done
for two days
never again will i stick a needle in the
roof in my [__] mouth well i didn't
stick it in there
the doctor [__] stuck it in but the
bottom line is i'm better now
this afternoon i gotta go for a haircut
and i gotta [__] go to the heart
doctor to make sure
that the gums being infected didn't
affect my heart
jesus christ this is what happens when
you become a [__] old man but the
problem was i did eight
caps in two weeks before i left
and the [__] thing got infected my
little dracula fang
got infected you can see it's down now
he [__] cut it again yesterday they
had to cut
the excess gums off can you [__]
believe that
i didn't feel the stitches but i tasted
the blood going down my throat
it's a [__] nightmare but guess what
it's over i gotta go back on august
night now
no more [__] stitches the heart feels
a lot [__] better listen
i did coke for 28 years i ain't going
nowhere
i ain't gonna i told my wife dear dagger
listen my heart is a [__] tank
first off i grew up in north bergen the
second hilliest city in the country i
walked up and down those [__] hills
that makes your heart stronger than
[__] dead i hit the bag
you know that makes your heart [__]
strong that makes that chest muscle
[__] strong
i'm eating good i'm sleeping good you
know i'm not eating any [__] garbage
food
my trap said listen i had i think i did
the shittiest [__] podcast i ever did
on monday
and all you [__] told me was
how good i looked i can't believe
it so thank you if i look that good
thank you
but uh i'm working out i'm drinking tons
of water you got to remember i work out
four days a week
every time i work out i drink two
[__] 50 ounce [__] glasses of
water
i'm pissing all day you understand me
this time i leave the house
i piss before i leave and by the time i
hit the [__] nine
i gotta pee again i gotta go behind the
bagel shop with my little hospital pia
you don't think i have it in the car i
have it in the [__] car
there's tons of times i pee right out of
the [__] light
i will i'm so good at it now i could
take my dick out put it on the cup
and pee right at the light waving people
how are you good to see you great poupon
you gotta see me at a [__] light dog
i can piss up a storm
but at the next light i gotta empty the
[__] piss out because i gotta drive
with one hand
carrying the container because the
container doesn't fit nowhere
and if that [__] thing spills in my
car my car's gonna smell worse than what
it does now
i have not washed that car since i got
it i got that car in january
and it's had that piss bottle in it
since i did the [__] surgery
i brought two bottles home the one
bottle's upstairs which i never [__]
use
and the other bottles in my [__] car
you know
and it stinks to death i remember going
into the city to shoot that show
and i still remember pulling up to the
[__] valet guy
at the at the parking building and he's
like where am i gonna put your car
and he started walking away from me i'm
like [__] i gotta pee
and i'm looking at him through the rear
view mirror i got my dick in the [__]
hospital cup
and i'm [__] peeing i'm peeing i'm
peeing i see him turn around
i'm still [__] peeing and by the time
he got to the car my dick was back in my
pants
and i'm holding my p he thought it was
like an iced tea he didn't know what the
[__] it was
it's he didn't see the container but if
you see my arm the way it was standing
you thought i would just have a nice
tear man
when he walked past me he goes park it
over here i go hold on one second
and i got out of the [__] car he
didn't see me and i emptied my pee in
the garbage can
and i just hit it a couple oh yeah i
emptied it right in the [__] garbage
can you know me i don't give a [__]
i put it back in my car i got paper
towels inside i wipe the inside up
and i throw the [__] paper towels in
the garbage and that's it
but i'm not putting up with that [__]
listen every time i get in that [__]
car
i gotta pee and if i pull over in a
parking lot and the cop sees me
i'm gonna get [__] if you pull over
in a park or in one of those [__]
truck stops and a cop sees you pissing
they're gonna charge you with sexual
assault they're gonna think you're
showing your dick to a truck driver
and next thing you know you're gonna be
have to [__] register as a sex
offender
in your neighborhood i can't have that
so i'd rather bear the shame and piss in
that [__] container
then take my dick out and become a
[__] sex offender in my [__]
neighborhood i don't need that [__] in
my life
nobody needs a sex offender in that
[__] neighborhood
anyway today we got the honor of uh
interviewing one of my [__] close
friends uh rudy sarzo we're gonna talk a
little about
cuba we've always talked about uh
music before but today i wanted to
switch it up you know rudy was one of
the first guys i went to lunch with
and he told me that he would never go
back to cuba while the [__]
administration is there and i was blown
the [__] away because every other cuban
has gone back there
thank god i have friends that are
[__] headstrong rudy's like i'm not
going back there
and i always respect like at first it
threw me off a little bit
but then i always respected him after
that because i understood what he was
saying
and i felt the same way after i'm like
[__] you but he's right
what did i forget do i have a shirt
[__] memory you know they're [__]
90 miles from us and they're [__]
doing [__] to people that it's just
[__] horrible
i'm out you know i'm cuban it's in my
heart there's nothing i could do
you know the last couple weeks i haven't
felt good about this because i really
want to help
and i don't know where to [__] start
but something will come to me and
eventually i could
be a part of this [__] revolution and
help the cuban people
anyway uh i got rudy sarzo for you i'll
check in with you afterwards enjoy
[__]
[Music]
go go what's so beautiful
how are you i'm blessed let's be honest
yeah awesome you on the road this
weekend
every weekend yeah uh it's back to the
grind we're trying to make up for what
we lost
last year plus new added dates for this
year so i'm pretty busy
yeah you're out the whole summer
yeah summer up until december right
right before christmas
no [__] yeah yeah good for you really
how you feeling
as long as things don't change
right yep yeah yeah
and it don't look good you know the
numbers are going up
yeah i don't know if they're tricking
you or they want people to vaccinate
themselves or whatever the [__] they're
doing but
people are already starting to panic a
little bit i'm okay
you know what the [__] you gonna do yeah
you know me too
yeah so what's going on buddy i miss you
you know i missed that i missed going to
porto's too you know i've been here 11
months
i haven't eaten cuban food yet it's such
a [__] pain in the ass to get the way
you need to go
to get cuban food that it just sucks and
once you're there
you can't find [__] parking you know
you gotta [__] walk two miles so
forget it it's just too rough
i gotta go to union city in a couple of
weeks anyway so i'll [__] go early
and
park the car on 48th street and walk
around a little bit and see how much
it's changed
yeah i well first of all you look
amazing man
your face you look happy yeah you look
you look rested you know
awesome awesome i am [__] arrested 11
months i've been resting
that's a good [__] rest that's longer
than [__]
tommy and goodfellas remember when he
was resting out by the bus stop and see
caucus i'm worse than him i've been
[__] resting up a store i sleep good
rudy
i [__] take everything i can to fall
asleep the melatonin
the the thc the cbd
i sleep [__] solid i get up to piss
at four in the morning i don't even know
where the [__] i'm going
i end up in the closet some days my wife
tells me i got up in the middle of night
to pee i don't remember [__]
so i'm good man but i'm happy you look
great i miss you
i feel good i feel good you know i miss
like 10 [__] dudes with all my heart
i miss breath i miss you
i miss a lot of people but it's good
that we have
zoom we could connect now we could do a
little [__] podcast i could call you
next week and do your little radio show
yeah yeah yeah what i wanted to talk to
you about today was because you were old
school
more old school than i am you were born
there you walked around there
i was born there but i got yanked out of
there
before i knew anything that was [__]
happening
talk to me about the cuban situation as
you see it
well listen as i see it is uh because i
was there when it began
and my only uh you know what took so
long
that's my holy question you know i've
been gone for 60
years what has it taken since the
revolution came in
62 years do people figure out that
communism
is not the way to go especially after
the cradle of communism
russia karl marx writing his book
you know lenin all the you know all of
them
and it fell communism fell
in in russia so isn't that a clue that
this thing does not work
you know you cannot turn humans into
robots
which is why communism socialism fascism
any dictatorship a dictatorship i don't
care it's left right middle up and down
behind you whatever it's going to turn
you into a robot
we are not robots we're human beings and
eventually
we get to a breaking point okay
if you take away everything from us
you're going to take fear
away from us and when we got no fear we
got nothing to lose
nothing not nothing else mattered but
freedom you know
i think that's what's going on right now
people are just [__]
they've had enough to cubans they've had
enough
you know i know i don't know firsthand
but i know from talking to my cousins
what it's like down there
you know they're well off they're part
of the revolution they're well
off their commies you know they have
money they have their bands they have
all that stuff
but i've spoken to other people that
have told me what's going on down there
and it's not [__] good
it's it's just inhumane and it's been
like that for years and we know that
you know in the 70s they turned our
family on us they tried to turn
yeah the family on you so yeah yeah
i mean uh it's a [__] brainwashed
mind [__] scientology class all in
itself i mean it's just a [__]
nightmare
it really is it's spanish scientology
[__] yeah
yeah now we're left in this position
that cubans in america feel
like i feel like [__] over this because
i want to be involved but i don't know
where to start
well listen uh
it all started with bay of pigs
that not being able to to be involved i
mean
listen even even castro fidel
started his revolution outside of cuba
he went on he returned i believe it was
mexico right so he returned from mexico
with the the with the first wave of
revolutionaries on that boat the grandma
you know that's that's that boat and it
was just a handful of
revolutionaries so they started
in the west oriente you know recruiting
uh farmers you know being to say the
julio
that was that was you know happening out
west it didn't happen in the middle
in havana you know so it it carried over
but it was an invasion of cubans that
started
not in the island it had origins outside
right that's not allowed anymore since
the bay of pigs
you know i mean for the people that i
was in cuba
i was uh 10 years old
10 years old when they picked 10 or 9.
so i remember
big pigs my family was there doing bagel
pigs and
we left in the middle and we were in
miami
during the the missile crisis the cuban
missile crisis right
so i remember everything you know and
i got to tell you of course you know we
didn't get first-hand information
in havana but we knew something was
going on there was a lot of mobilization
going on you know
and after
after it happened you know certain
information came out
and then once i got to the united states
i got the other side of what also
happened so i put you know putting two
and two
together but the thing was is that
the la brigado and cinco serosas the
brigade which was the cuban army
that trained outside of cuba to attack
you know fidel they were the only ones
that went in
in land the the the
the us navy was held back
they were they were ready to go but
kennedy
got a phone call from khrushchev and
says if you guys
if you if the u.s navy attacks cuba
you you're starting world war iii so he
backed down
so the brigade went in they're the ones
who flew in
you know they had the airplanes and all
that and attack cuba they were shut down
and check this out here i am 10 years
old
you know before the revolution just you
know life was normal i
you know come home from school i will
watch cartoons
just like every other kid in just about
every country right
after the invasion of pigs they captured
uh cuban soldiers that went in right
and they and all of a sudden no more
cartoons
at that time all it was it was uh the
jury
you know the judges they had judgment
which meant that they were brought
in and this is on television television
there were televised
they're bringing them in and they made
the accusations
next day they had him shot
shot on live tv fusilla fusillamiento
in live tv here i am a kid and i'm
watching i'm watching
you know man getting shot right live tv
okay this is this is what i experienced
still living in cuba
you know and ever since
the day of pigs it has not
it's not the us government has not
supported any invasion
coming from the united states to cuba
now when they went down there 2506
that was the crew that battle was in
jose battle
yeah and they got in castro was already
waiting for them
he had put knives standing upside down
in the ocean so when they stepped
they would cut their feet they knew they
were set up
the united states the the bay of pigs
guy that trained they trained supposedly
in northern new jersey too
fidel started his campaign up here in
union city
then he took it to tampa then he took it
to mexico
and he built you know he built up as he
went along you know
yeah if you remember in the movies in
new orleans they said that uh
[__] the guy that shot kennedy was
passing out flies
he was anti-communist that for a while
then he was communist it was like he was
like a [__] setup
but castro started his recruitment
you're right in the united states
it started in union city he went
somewhere else new york city
tampa and then mexico and then he
[__]
took the grandma in and that was it the
end of that [__] tune so
yeah and then after they got captured
like battle
battle didn't get shot
and he remembers them getting saved
and they got taken to the orange boat
and there at the orange bowl kennedy
gave a speech
but his wife stole the show jacqueline
said some [__] that really got to the
[__] soldiers and
but under their breath they all knew
that kennedy had [__] them
they knew that kennedy had [__] them
you know so
that's the history there but
what i don't know is the question you
ask yourself
how could they stay like that for years
i've been saying how can
communism be alive and kicking 90 miles
from the united states
it's [__] disgusting it's just an
embarrassment
now i don't think it's the united states
fault with the embargo you know people
are blaming the united states
they want biden to [__] go in i mean
a couple of days ago when we spoke
yeah i was telling you that i think
sunday night there was 3 000 cubans in
front of the white house
you know they're starting to go in front
of the white house now and i think
that's a great move but i don't see you
know the united states has their hands
tied rudy
you know i don't know if russia would
stick up for cuba now
i don't know if china would stick up for
cuba the way [__] russia has been
acting the last couple years
this could also be a setup this could
also be a russian setup
you know cuba's been acting [__]
weird the last couple years
remember a couple years ago they had the
all the people from dc went down there
and they started getting headaches oh
yeah
because fidel and his people were yeah
doing some type of ring to
noise that it's like a dog whistle
you can't [__] hear it certain
people's ears hear it and all those
people got [__] up they had nausea
you know cuba's been acting [__]
weird lately so
something's going on down there but i
think it's the russians just trying to
be high-handed you never know
never know never know i mean the only
thing that i can give you you know my
perception based on my own experience
from being there you know uh
and also in school you know our
education in school especially
pre-revolution
was you know we were taught the basics
i learned at a very early age about the
spanish-american war
you know it uh the have you heard about
in
the main it's a ship called maine no
okay this is well well well spain or
what cuba was still
a colony of spain right and the cubans
were trying to
you know get get a just like the united
states did with england
you know stop being a colony and become
a a nation you know a country
and uh by the span you know they they
they just confide
the this spanish
armada basically the army you know
so so what they knew they knew that
somehow they had to bring in
the united states you know to help him
so there's conspiracy theories about
this
that the boat the ship the american ship
that was docked at havana bay
this is i'm talking about 1899
right before 1902 is when cuba
officially
became a country so it's pre-1902
over 100 years ago right so this
american ship was parked
was docked right there in the uh havana
bay
and somehow it blows up
there's there's theories about that it
was the spanish that did it
but there was theories that the cubans
did it to blame the spanish
so eventually what happened is teddy
roosevelt
the rough riders came down the barrels
on one hill
along with with with the
cuban farmers you know the word
guajiro yes is actually war
hero war hero that's what the americans
were calling
the farm farmers war and they thought it
was guajiro
right so the farmers are got involved
they became part of the uh
of the of the army there was like you
know it's called the spanish-american
war
but it's really the cubans were fighting
along with the americans against the
spanish you know
and eventually you know they got uh
liberated and as a gift
i said thank you i said thank you
to the united states guantanamo
that territory that is the base was
given
to the united states one time when what
is known today as guantanamo bays
as a thank you for liberating cuba
from the spanish
that's [__] amazing i never knew that
i had no yeah
they featured that in school they oh
they used to in cuba when i was a kid
you know so that's like fundamental
stuff yeah
yeah i didn't learn much about cuba it's
what i read you know
what i read on my own that i learned
about cuba and i'm
i'm upset that i didn't ask more
questions when my mom and dad were alive
well my mom was alive you know i was
raised very anti-castro
i was raised in a community that was
very anti-castro
i saw the [__] rage in their faces
you know some people say ah joe's a
jerk-off
but some people look at you and they go
joe's a [__] [__]
i mean people would lose their mind when
i was a kid
i didn't know what this hatred was about
so i had to actually read
look it up and go holy [__] these
[__] people had a hatred in their
heart that was
just rough my mother there was a lady at
that was a bartender at my mother's bar
that she would make me rub her head
every day
she would tell me rub rub rub my head
and i could feel she would make me rub
her head
so i could feel the metal bullets she
had in the head
she was pregnant and she passed uh like
a stopping cube and they fired on her
and she still had the [__] bullets
floating around her head i mean you
could feel them
in her head i mean just the [__] that i
was told was just
it was just horrible what they did to
these people you know
so this has been ingrained in their
[__] psyche
for years a lot of those pre-revolutions
people are dead
i mean thank god you still have your mom
she's still alive but
i bet your mom would be a [__] great
guest to tell you exactly
what the [__] was going on down there
you know yeah but it's painful it's
painful to go there very painful you
know yeah
very very painful they got everything
taken from them
they got lied to and then they got
[__] how would you fee
you know how would you feel i mean they
they got [__] they got everything
taken away from them
well let me tell you this it took my
family about a year to get
all the documentation and visas and
passports and
and you know purchased a ticket
all of that and it was done clandestine
because if any if we had
defense committees which mean it was a
every block had a watch
it would be people watching you watching
your every move that you made and if
they found out
something about you they will report it
and then you were you were you you
disappear that's it
they take you away and you never heard
of after that
uh to to leave
everything behind knowing that you
cannot give it to
any of your relatives pass it on to your
mom you know to
to my grandmother nothing we left the
house
as a matter of fact we were not even
dressed to to leave the country
by that meaning that back in 1961 it's
going to be 40 years
in september that we left 60 years
60 years that we left in september
1961 and we you know we just had like
three clothes back
back in 1961 people dressed up to go on
a plane you know you had to wear a suit
and a tie
you know not like it is to it now but
you know back then so we left like you
know normal street clothes and then
somewhere along the way we changed into
our
flying you know traveling clothes and we
had things in duffel bags
they call it chorizo sausages duffle
bags
not even suitcases because we couldn't
not walk around with suitcase
if you purchase a suitcase man you were
going somewhere where you're going
you start getting questions and if you
have multiple suitcases because
everybody in the family
has got one or two then that really
raises the flag so everything
was done like you know in duffel bags
you can pull them up and put them inside
of a paper bag and nobody knew that what
you were carrying
you know so in in the middle of the
night before
before dawn we we
got in a car we headed towards the
airport
you know we changed on our way there
and i got to tell you to know that there
is no coming back
see if you're an immigrant you can
always go back to your country
but if you're a refugee a refugee
you're running away and you're getting
away from from
from a dangerous lifestyle something
that takes away your freedom
you're not going to come back until that
problem is resolved if ever in your
lifetime
and we knew that and that's the anger
that we all have we have no closure we
cannot even say goodbye to our family
they know one day they go where are they
and we are in miami and
and there's no texting no cell phones
back then 61.
so the information trickles by writing a
letter
to somebody to give to to somebody in my
family
because they were watching the postman
to see you know if and if and if it's a
letter coming from from miami
to let's say my grandmother they were
gonna
they were gonna grab it and read read
what was in the letter what information
and not even give it to
to my grandmother you know it was it's
horrible
horrible horrible situation 60 years ago
can you imagine what it's like
right now i can't even wrap my head
around that
you know my wife told me yesterday that
my cousin
got a tweet out about a week ago
my cousin emmy and it said that
she didn't really want to tweet or say
anything because
she didn't want to get thrown in jail
they're just throwing people in [__]
jail right now
part of me wants to start off some
[__] problems up here but
i also feel that maybe they'll do
something to your family in cuba
who the [__] knows if i start taking it
to twitter and instagram and [__]
marching and
you know cursing [__] fidel i don't
know what they're gonna [__] do you
know if you watch
the 30 for 30 about the duke brothers
the one that
the two brothers that played major
league baseball that one world series
yeah what el duque went through before
when his brother left
was rough they wouldn't let him play
baseball because of his brother
they would throw eggs at his [__]
house every day you know
they would cut the food at his house
because his brother left you know he had
no choice
but to [__] swim to [__] bahamas
and then
the yankees got him from the bahamian
jail before they got thrown back in cuba
if you ever get a chance to watch that
30 for 30 you'll be moved to [__]
tears it's it's
it's tremendous i thought it was one of
the best ones
but just to see the way they live you
know
people don't know about the biggest star
in cuba celia cruz
[__] fidel yanked her house you know
fidel wanted
fidel got pissed because she didn't
scent when she was singing
she didn't make eye contact with him she
wouldn't look at that [__] you
know because she knew he ended up
killing her cousin
he ended up taking a house he destroyed
[__] cellular cruise you know
and a lot of people don't know this [__]
but we don't we know what's going on
down there
and it hurts you know it bothers me
but what can you do where do you [__]
start rudy what do we do
if you send money they take 70 percent
now
you send five dollars your family gets a
dollar [__] 50.
yeah yeah you want food they take off
the top you send medicines they take
some off the top
you know you send a bottle of aspirins
they get three [__] aspirins yeah
it's it's just a nightmare yeah
one thing about the the consciousness
that the obvious you know communism in
cuba
has spread is the
that that all their problems stem from
the embargo and you and i know
that if we walk into walmart
everything's made in china
china communist country what keeps cuba
from buying from china we have no
no say so in that cuba has has done
business with every other country in the
world
what once the embargo if ever is lifted
and hopefully is lifted
after cuba is liberated cuba will become
a favorite nation which means that we
start pumping money
into cuba meaning yours and mine
tax dollars that we pay starts going
back
to the cuban government not to the
people
but to the cuban government because it's
still a communist country
right so lifting the embargo see people
are not rebelling because there's no
food
people are rebelling because they have
no freedom
you can't buy freedom it doesn't matter
how much money we send to cuba
you'll still be prisoners in that island
which is [__] crazy to me
it's crazy that like when my uncle
went back he said he said he could stay
at the hotel but his family wasn't
allowed to visit him
yeah i know what kind of [__] is that
that's apartheid
that's apartheid and nobody connects
that instead oh boy
the people in cuba are not allowed to
enjoy
their own native uh no
nothing that's apartheid it is
people don't know that they're not even
allowed in that like if i go to cuba
and stay at a hotel my family's not live
in the hotel i know
especially if they have dark skin
especially if they're dark-skinned
so a lot of people don't [__] notice
[__] that it's that racist it's that
[__] uh you know bad to live off
three eggs a month or whatever the [__]
they live off yeah
you know yeah it's just a goddamn shame
and like i said i wish
i knew where to start you know i think
talking about it
like what we're doing right now and
people listening this will educate
a lot of people i mean you dropped some
[__] knowledge today
i had no idea about the wajitos and
[__]
and uh guantanamo bay and whatnot
but i just don't know where to start
you know i don't know where to [__]
start whether it starts on
social media whether it starts by us
going to the nation's capital
and marching you know i don't know where
to start and i don't want to bring
harm to the family that i have in cuba
yeah you know the reason why why i'm i'm
i'm not
elated elated that this is happening
it's because
there's going to be a lot of bloodshed
and most likely you're going to get the
same result
as in venezuela which is
nothing nothing happened they they rebel
in venezuela
you know a couple of years ago and still
still the people are going through very
hard times and
listen any communist country especially
in the caribbean and south america
with such fertile agricultural resources
cuba in particular coffee
tobacco sugarcane and of course you're
not
you're not going to survive only on
those products but when i'm talking
about
how fertile the land is to be able to
export all of this around the world if
you really want to sustain
your your your citizens agriculture
there is food there's food there but
recently i've been watching interviews
with farmers
and the system is broken they sit there
because they
the farmers have to sell the the uh
their crops
to the government but the problem
they're having is the government
is not buying their crops they're
letting the crops
rot so they're sitting there with rotted
crops
and they can't sell that crop because
you know they have to that's that's
allocated
for the government it's it's crazy
what's going on there
crazy
i just don't know what to do rudy and
that's what's eating me alive
you know i will start with this talking
about it
you know letting people know what's
going on down there
i think you know i've always cared
but i just didn't know where the [__] to
start yeah i know this has to be
i mean we could come up with money get
some boats go down there and save some
people but
there's a million people that want to
get the [__] out of that right now i
know i know
well you know unfortunately what goes in
comes out the same way it's it began
62 years ago with a revolution
and it's going to go out with another
revolution
that's from from being there when that
happened
and my perception of what's going on now
it ain't going to change unless
it's a reversal and the only way to to
do it
is the same way that it came in the same
way is going to go out
so what do you suggest that somebody
gets a little boat like grandma
and starts in mexico i mean listen we
have tons of [__] uh
cuban americans that are willing to help
you you know what this
those [__] cubans are crazy so what
what what do we do do we get boats and
go down there
i mean i don't think the united states
is going to send anybody down there
right now
no no of course not i think we have our
own [__] problems and i get it i
understand yeah so this has to be
like a clandestine operation
of cuban americans this is the only
people that are going to take this over
yeah you know
yeah historically there's always been
leadership
like when
during the spanish-american war prior to
that
we had jose marti leader
and he's just one one of many you know
that was that were around masayo
antonio masayo you know all of these
leaders who were either military
or or conscientious leadership
you know and i i don't see a leader
right now i see a mass revolt
almost like the french revolution just
people
[__] had it you know with it but at
the end of the day
once when god willing things get
resolved
there has to be somebody to come in and
say okay we're gonna place order
and it should be into internal internal
you know or at least cuban might be a
cuban in exile
that comes in with the purest
intentions you cannot replace a bad
system with another bad
system the next system that that
government that comes into cuba has to
be
saints saints you know like
the best leadership any country
could ever have otherwise
we have the same problem but the uh
apollo ops
opposite you know well see that's the
problem i see that
i don't want somebody to go back in
there with bad intentions again
yeah you know they're going to go up
they're going to come in and say they
have good intentions
but once they're there the intentions
become bad again
yeah that's what i don't want cuba to go
through like a bunch of cuban americans
from miami
that are [__] yeah who's going down
there and then yeah
it getting to that [__] head you know
so that's what we
that's what i'm worried about i hope
this ends up like marielle
i hope the government says listen you
went out let's get the [__] out of it
get the [__] out have your family come
get you
uh send planes i i doubt the united
states said they will not take cubans
so they will have to go somewhere else
canada will take them you know but i
think it's going to be a mass exodus
i hope that's how it ends instead of all
the bloodshed
and the fighting and [__] like that
that's what i'm holding yeah i
i i are you aware that it was obama who
lifted
the the one wet foot one dry foot
yes law yeah it was obama so now anybody
that
you know comes on a boat from cuba they
get sent back
even even if they are if they are caught
in in dry land because
that's you know they're illegal so
send them right back so that's why
people are really not
you know taking their the risk of going
you know
on a boat or usually in a raft not even
a boat
a raft made out of like pieces of junk
that floats and they throw themselves
into the
shark infested golf you know with
uh hurricanes i mean the chances
are survivable are so minimal but they
rather risk their lives
than to just uh live you know
live under communism you know i always
think of that
what it takes how bad is your life
when i get in the raft in new jersey to
swim over to long island
that's that's the distance you know like
the typical 90 miles
probably like the tip of jersey like if
i go all the way to wildwood
and get a [__] boat i mean how bad is
your life
that you're willing to die in a [__]
raft eating saltine crackers
yeah because they have a system the
cubans have a system they go from a
certain part of the island
they leave at a certain time you know
they have to bring in certain
[__] things water saltines you know
they bring a lot of [__]
and then it's just a brutal 90 miles
it's
there's no [__] clouds you're in the
[__] sun if you jump in the water
there's nothing but [__] sharks
i mean it's a no-win-win situation
there's a no-win situation
so think about how bad your life has to
be
i'm sorry that is it no and that is if
the cuban coast guard
doesn't get you and machine you machine
gun you
shoots you down because it you know if
they see you
they're going to kill you they kill
children they kill adults it doesn't
matter
you know they see they see a raft you
know the coast guard the cuban cost
right yeah right so you have to like
avoid that
too so you know the risks are so high
have you been to have you been to the
raft museum
there's a rafter it's in key west
to actually see these
it's it's it's it's pieces of junk
with a rope together and these people
cross the goal from that
it's unbelievable i won't even go
go in the swimming pool with one of
these things
it's uh it's very scary and i'm happy
that
you brought all these things up today so
people know what the
like i said i i have a limited knowledge
you were born there you were raised
there you were there for a couple years
under the [__] uh
maybe a year or two under this [__]
you know i knew you would bring light to
this and i know i know
yeah how much it affects you i still
remember being at porto's with you
and saying to you are you going to go to
cuba and you're like not in a million
[__] years
yeah as long as that government's in
there i can't go back and you were dead
[__] serious and i'm like [__] rudy
is no nonsense when it comes to this
[__]
but you never forgot you were there you
saw the atrocities
you saw the lie hatching you know like
when you go to miami
you don't order a rum and coke you order
a menterita that means a lie
you know that's what they're called in
miami they don't say rum and coke or
whatever the [__] they're called
they just say give me a mentee mentee
that means a lie in spanish so
that's uh it's just [__] crazy rudy i
hated
to have you on for us to talk about this
[__] nightmare in cuba but
i wanted to have you on to show people a
different perspective
and you [__] came through on it
so thank you i i i've gotten requests to
come on on other shows
and i'm making yours the only one
because you and i
we know is in our blood we know this
we we lift this you know i mean so it's
not a an opinion
it's just based on experience
well i i i never lived at rudy i saw the
pain
i saw the pain of it of what it did to
people
i saw the pain in my mother i saw the
pain in my stepfather
and i saw the pain and all those other
cuban americans when i was growing up
and it did something to me
you lived there because you see we were
just talking about what was going on in
cuba once you leave cuba and you come to
the united states
it's the other it's it's it's act
two of of of of the
of the nightmare i do because all of a
sudden
you know i have me you know when i was
living when i was
living in cuba i was cuban everybody
else was cuban
it didn't matter if they came from
poland during the uh you know during the
nazis
or or there were chinese leaving you
know escaping from monster tomb you know
it didn't matter we were all cubans then
i come to the united states and it's
like
well you're different from everybody and
that guy is this thing and this guy's
this other thing and everything you know
once i moved to new jersey
you know how west new york is you know
especially in 1961
was there in 63 that's when i got there
when kennedy got a shot
it was like you had your little section
they had italians and the polish and
then the irish and then the cubans we
were like
we were like the smallest minority in
west new york
you know not anymore but that was it and
man you know
i went from rudolph roloff to rudolph
and now i'm rudy
the teacher is naming me rudy first
thing in school i never i don't even
know
who he was talking to when he when i was
putting my books inside
of my uh my desk and he's i hear it rudy
rudy i'm going like
then i lift my head and so it says yeah
you and i go no
rudolph says no you're rudy from now on
the adaptation man you know losing your
identity losing everything
i'm i'm talking about a truth my
experience
yes i survived it i survived it and i
because i survived it and i experienced
it yeah i'm probably a better person
than i would have been
if if i did not have these challenges
but it is
challenging just because you leave
communism that
doesn't mean like okay wow this is
fantastic okay so
now i smooth sailing oh no man it's it's
still
a rough ride
it's rough fruity and i don't know how
to [__] uh get this started
but it starts with you today i mean i'm
happy that
you took the time to let these
[__] know what's going on down
there
anytime anything for you me motto
anything hey how are you doing
mate maybe someday we can do the podcast
dailabana i'll be there with you
that'll be [__] great man that would
be great rudy
what else is going on in your world the
wife is good touring hey everybody i'm
i'm blessed
uh touring doing some shows with the
guests who i have a big announcement
coming up
uh next week and uh i'm blessed beyond
words
blessed be on words yeah well i miss you
with all my mission too you know i miss
going to lunch with you
and i miss just seeing you you know i'm
six doors down from florentine
we always talk about you i saw him this
morning at the gym with his son
and he always says that you're the
reason why he had that son
because you told him [__] to get it
together and [__] so i saw him this
morning with his son it was great to see
him and
uh it's great to see you rudy and let's
keep in touch about this cuban
you got it you gotta remind me yeah we
could inform
help you know i don't wanna send money
to
some [__] thing i don't want to do
that i really want to
be involved you know so uh let me know
and
thank you maybe this week are you
leaving this week
yeah i'm living tonight actually i'm
going to
yeah okay and then you're going on the
road from there i'm going
straight from miami i'll be going to
somewhere
in maine or outside of portland
but i'm gonna be i'm gonna be at the
golden nugget in atlantic city
coming up in september so if you're not
gigging
let's do it really come on down yeah
yeah what's the date
i got on my calendar i'll text it to you
okay
wasn't gonna say to you uh [__] there
was something i had to tell oh
maybe next week we could do another
guitar lesson okay
you got it it was really you scared the
[__] out of me that day
i've never seen you like that i have to
tell you i've never seen you like that
but all the pieces came together
do you know that that was the last time
i took a xanax the day i took the guitar
lesson from you
and before that it had been like three
months since i took a xanax
you were so intense on that guitar
lesson
that i was like [__] i've never seen
this side of rudy put your thumb down
finger up guitar out put your shoulders
up
holy [__] and now i don't use my thumb
and now the thumb is behind that the
pressure is tremendous
so that was i was with you and i'm like
i remember getting
off with you and going no wonder he's
the bass player that he is
no wonder why he should be in the
[__] hall of fame
holy [__] that was a guitar lesson right
in front of me i was like
i had to [__] take a little football
i was like jesus christ
this is as intense as could be so yeah
let's get together next week i'm doing
crazy training for you
all right i don't have the whole thing i
just got the big boy
i just got that [__] i'm no [__]
randy rhodes
but uh i'm trying brother but thank you
very much
i hope this thing works out and uh let's
talk next week when you get back
you got it god bless i love you brother
god bless you thank you thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
all right you bad [__] i hope
you learned something i hope you enjoyed
rudy sarso i did
i learned i didn't know about juarito i
didn't know about guantanamo bay
i knew about the spanish-american war
but i never knew all those little
details he dropped on me
thank you very much for enjoying it
again i'm very sorry about
monday's podcast i was a little [__]
lost with the therapy and whatever
it happens i'm getting back now guys i
have a plan
uh i'm gonna start doing guest sets
pretty soon i feel in my balls
once my two [__] uh stitches heal up
i'm gonna just start i gotta get out of
the house at night i gotta do a little
something i'm gonna do it my way though
i'm gonna do comedy my way i'll probably
end up getting the residency around here
and i'll do comedy on wednesday nights
and friday nights only i want the
weekends at home with my daughter
uh no more running around the [__]
country if i do go across the country
it'll be one [__] night to a theater
you know i miss milwaukee i miss
cleveland i miss chicago
i miss utah i miss [__] texas i miss
a lot of [__] states you
you guys know i've been on the road for
[__] 20 something years
i know this whole [__] country back
and forth and i love it
you know these [__] jerk clothes i
went to spain [__] you you ain't going
nowhere now
with kovis you better get [__] cozy
and get to know west virginia [__]
you better get the no [__] in uh fargo
north dakota
you better get to know south dakota
cause ain't nobody traveling abroad and
this is the way to go wyoming
is a great state montana is a great
state watch the show with kevin costner
my
my brother was telling me about the
other night some show from [__]
montana there's more millionaires
in montana and new york city i don't
know what the [__] he was talking about
do not forget laughing gas is still
there's a little bit left
until the [__] uh next batch so if
you're in studio city stop by
the ice cream [__] dispensary the ice
cream shop dispensary
tell them uncle joey sent you and
they'll take great care
i love you thank you very much for
supporting and thank you for still being
here
i'll see you monday morning tip top
magoo
and now for a word from our
[__] sponsors jack
all right i want to thank you guys i
want to thank rudy
but i want to thank our sponsors that
are the best the joint is brought to you
by
bowl and branch tremendous sheets
there's nothing more important than a
good night's sleep
you gotta have nice sheets bowling brand
sheets are ultra soft
check out the signature hem sheets their
best sellers for a good reason
they get softer with every wash these
sheets are buttery soft and lightweight
it's perfect for all seasons they come
in a variety of colors
and in every size from twin to
california king
and like i told you earlier bowling
brand sheets are made by craftsmen who
earn a fair
living wage these workers earn their pay
and respect they deserve
all of bowling branch products are made
using safe
fair conditions not like other people we
won't mention
get ready for this the bowling branch
guarantee enjoy any product
worry free for 30 nights look at you've
been looking to get sheets you've been
looking for a pregnant
a present for grandma uncle joey
pete the neighbor this is the way to go
they're gonna love them
plus you have a product worry free for
30 nights
to experience the best sheets you've
ever felt choose bowling brands you
could try them worry free
for 30 nights with free shipping and
returns my listeners get an exclusive
fifteen percent off your first set of
sheets with promo code joey
at bowlingbranch.com that's bowl
b-o-l-l and branch b-r-a-n-c-h
dot com use promo code joey you're gonna
love these sheets
i like to guarantee they make it because
you're gonna fall in love with them
that backs what they're telling you
right now so go to bowlingbranch.com
use promo code joey and get the best
sheets you ever felt
in your life when you choose bowling
branch the joint is also brought to you
by
cbd lion i don't know how many times i
got to tell you about these guys but
they're tremendous
if it wasn't for them i wouldn't have
made it out of the surgery the tape
the bath balls the cream it's just
they're just tremendous the gummy bears
and the new ones they have have
melatonin in them so you're going to
sleep
like a baby you have the roll-on you got
the cbd weed
when it comes to cbd cbd lion is the
best
available source to you read up on their
website
look at the third party lab results you
won't be sorry
com cbdlion.com joey for 20
off i want to thank manscape
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
bowling branch
i want to thank all of you this upstair
everybody who
sponsored our podcast but i also want to
thank you guys for watching and
listening
and for always supporting us have a
great [__] weekend
we'll be back monday morning tip top
[__] magoo
i love you savages
[Music]
you